Prof: Good morning
everyone.
Augustus founded the
Julio-Claudian dynasty.
The name says it all:
Julio-Claudian,
Julio for the Julian side of
the family, Julius Caesar and
Augustus;
the Claudian for the Claudian
side of the family.
That was Augustus' wife
from--her side of the family,
excuse me, the Claudian side of
the family.
And there were four emperors in
the Julio-Claudian dynasty.
These were Tiberius,
Caligula, Claudius,
and Nero.
Every one of them,
all four, made an important
contribution to the evolution of
Roman architecture,
and we'll talk about the
contributions of those four
today.
But we'll also see that the
single most important
contribution,
from the standpoint of Roman
architecture,
was by Nero,
the notorious emperor Nero,
which is why I do call this
lecture "Notorious Nero and
His Amazing Architectural
Legacy."
An architectural legacy that
would have been impossible
without some of the earlier
concrete constructions that
we've already discussed,
specifically the
frigidaria of Pompeii and
also the thermal bath at Baia,
which I remind you of here.
The so-called Temple of
Mercury, we see it again with
its dome made out of concrete
construction,
a view from the exterior.
And down here,
at the left,
a view of the interior of the
monument,
and I remind you of the way in
which is that designed so that
light streams through the
oculus in the dome,
down onto the sides of the
wall, creating light effects:
a circle that corresponds to
the shape of the opening above,
and then falling initially on
the pool of water that would
have been located there,
as well as across the walls,
which probably would have
been--
that were certainly stuccoed
over--and probably would have
been covered with mosaic.
So a very spectacular interior
indeed,
and one again that had an
important impact,
as we'll see,
on the architectural designs of
the Roman emperor Nero.
I want to begin though with the
first of the Julio-Claudian
emperors, and that is with
Tiberius.
And you see a portrait of
Tiberius now on the screen,
just to give you a sense of
what he looked like.
Tiberius, again the son of
Livia by a former marriage,
the elder son of Livia by a
former marriage,
who becomes emperor of Rome
right after Augustus.
And the portrait that you see
here is a marble portrait of
Tiberius that is now in the Ny
Carlsberg Glyptothek in
Copenhagen.
Tiberius was emperor of Rome
from 14 to 37 A.D.,
and with regard to
architecture,
he completed projects begun by
Augustus.
He also was responsible for
restoring Republican buildings
that had fallen into severe
disrepair by his reign,
and this included several
temples, a basilica,
warehouses, and also a theater.
Tiberius also initiated some
new building projects in Rome.
These included a Temple to the
Divine Augustus,
Temple to Divus
Augustus,
his divine adoptive father,
because Augustus was made a
god, as Caesar had been before
him,
at his death.
Tiberius also put up a series
of arches to his relatives,
and also a camp for the
Praetorian Guard.
But what we'll see about
Tiberius is that his real
passion was not the public
architecture that Augustus had
been so fond of--
think the Forum of Augustus and
the Temple of Mars Ultor,
or the Ara Pacis Augustae,
which were among Augustus' most
important building projects.
Tiberius was interested instead
in private architecture--
architecture in a sense for
himself and his nearest and
dearest--
and he began a palace on the
Palatine Hill.
He did not think the small,
modest House of Augustus,
despite the fact that it had
those nicely painted walls,
he did not think that that
befit his own grandeur,
and he began a major palace on
the Palatine Hill,
on the northwest side of the
Palatine Hill.
And he renovated and built
villas elsewhere,
outside of Rome,
especially on the spectacular
Island of Capri.
And indeed, during the reign of
Augustus,
and also the reign of Tiberius,
that family,
the Augustan and Julio-Claudian
family,
built twelve villas--count
them, twelve villas--
on the Island of Capri,
one more spectacular than the
next.
It's worth mentioning,
by the way, that Augustus'
taste, even in villas,
was somewhat more modest than
Tiberius.
Augustus used to decorate his
villa,
we are told,
with dinosaur bones and things
like that,
of historical interest,
whereas Tiberius spared no
expense in introducing every
luxury possible into his villas.
With regard to the palace on
the Palatine Hill,
the so-called Domus Tiberiana,
I just want to mention it in
passing.
There's very little that
survives of the substructures
that Tiberius was responsible
for beginning,
for that palace.
They were made out of concrete
construction,
and you can see here what's
called the Clivus Palatinus,
which is a ramp way leading
from the Roman Forum,
up to the Palatine Hill.
And you can see some of the
remains of those substructures
over here.
The ones that we see were
probably restored later and may
or may not date to the Tiberian
period,
but they give you some idea of
the sort of construction that he
began on the Palatine Hill.
And I mention this just because
we'll see that Caligula and some
of the other emperors continued
to add to this palace,
and then the entire Palatine
Hill is redesigned by the
emperor Domitian in the late
first century A.D.
Much more interesting and much
more--and there's much more
information for us to look
at--are the villas on the island
of Capri.
And I'm going to show you one,
the best preserved,
from that island,
the so-called Villa Jovis:
the Villa Jovis,
the Villa of Jupiter,
which is an interesting name,
when you think about it,
for a villa for the emperor
Tiberius.
The Villa Jovis,
which was put up sometime in
the years in which Tiberius was
emperor;
that is, from 14 to 37 A.D.
It's a spectacular place,
beautifully situated.
And I'm going to take you there
today.
Now the only way to get to the
island of Capri,
which by the way is one of my
very favorite places in the
world;
I don't know how many of you've
been there, but it's quite
extraordinary--the island of
Capri.
You can't jet to the Island of
Capri,
you have to arrive there by
boat, and most people take a
boat,
unless they have a private
yacht, but those of us who
don't,
have to take a boat either from
Naples,
usually a hydrofoil--although
they have larger boats as well--
a hydrofoil from Naples or from
Positano.
And I actually show you--this
is a view on the left-hand side
of the screen of Positano on the
Amalfi Coast.
You go down to the beach;
there's a place where you can
pick up a hydrofoil.
It takes a very short time,
half an hour or so,
less, a little bit less,
to get over to the Island of
Capri from Positano.
So we're sitting on one of
those hydrofoils--
or at least eight of us are,
because that's usually what
they fit--
and we're making our way from
Positano toward Capri.
As you go there,
if the weather is good enough,
and if the sea is calm enough,
they will take you to see the
famous grottos,
the Green Grotto and also the
Blue Grotto.
And again I can just give you a
little sense here of--in this
view--of how blue is blue.
I mean, it's really a neon
blue, when you go to see the
Blue Grotto.
It's a spectacular sight and a
very special color blue that you
really don't see anywhere else
in the world.
So they'll drive you around in
the hydrofoil to see the
grottos,
and then you eventually get to
the dock at Capri,
and this is what you see as you
get off the boat at the island
of Capri: again a very beautiful
spot to visit.
As you go up,
you make your way from the dock
up to the funicular.
You take the funicular up to
the main part of town,
and one of the first things you
see is the popular Bar Tiberio.
I show it to you,
not to--it's a fun place to
go--
but I show it to you mainly
because it's one of these
examples of the way in which the
Roman emperors have had a
lasting impact,
even today, that so many of
these bars and restaurants and
so on are named for Rome's
emperors,
or for some of the monuments
that we've been studying in the
course of this semester.
And this bar is no exception,
and in fact if you go through
the doors that lead into the
interior of the bar,
you will see a portrait of
Tiberius etched on the doorway.
So Tiberius very much lives and
thrives in the center of
downtown Capri still today.
What most tourists go to Capri
to see,
besides just to walk around a
magnificent island and to test
out some of the beaches,
which tend to be on the rocky
side,
is to see the most famous rocks
of Capri.
And these are the so-called
Faraglioni.
You see them here.
You go up to the so-called
Gardens of Augustus,
and then up to a spot where you
can see these particularly well.
They're magnificent.
They are the landmark spot on
the island of Capri,
and they have survived coastal
landslides and sea erosion,
to look as wonderful as they
still do today.
And this is,
of course, the photo op on the
island.
I don't think there's anyone
who visits Capri who doesn't
take a photo or have a photo
taken of themselves at the
Faraglioni.
The villa that I want to show
you is again the best preserved
villa of Tiberius on Capri.
And again I mentioned that it's
called the Villa Jovis,
and it dates to 14 to 37 A.D.
It's a trek to get up there.
You have to walk essentially.
The streets are such that there
are no cabs or cars that can get
you there.
You have to make it on your own.
And there are two paths.
I've made the mistake of taking
the more arduous path,
which looks like this,
to get up to the top,
but there's another path also
that takes you by some very
attractive houses and villas,
which are fun to see.
And you will see the largest
lemons--
has anyone ever been on the
island of Capri?--
you'll see the largest lemons
on Capri,
as well as on the Amalfi Coast
in general,
that you've ever seen anywhere:
gigantic lemons on lemon trees,
as you make your way up to the
Villa of the Villa Jovis.
Now here is a plan of the Villa
Jovis, as well as a
cross-section,
from the Ward-Perkins textbook.
And if we look first at the
cross-section,
at the uppermost part of the
screen, you will see the way
this building was made.
You will see that the
architects have taken advantage
of developments in concrete
construction to create a series
of barrel vaults in tiers,
and those barrel vaults in
tiers are where--
are the cisterns of the villa,
where the water was kept to
supply the baths and the kitchen
and so on,
of the villa.
You see those there,
and in this plan down here you
can see the cisterns again and
the way in which a pavement has
been placed on top of those
tiers of barrel vaults,
to create a very large court
here.
The entranceway into Tiberius'
villa on Capri was over here.
You can see a series of
columns, four in total,
that you see as you make your
way into the entranceway of the
villa.
Along this side of the villa,
which is the southern side of
the villa,
you see the baths--not
surprisingly placed on the
southern side--
extensive bath structure for
the emperor.
On the western side you see a
series of rooms that are for the
entourage of Tiberius.
The kitchen is located on this
side as well.
And then perhaps the most
important room of the house,
from our standpoint,
the hall or the aula--
a-u-l-a--the aula of
Tiberius' villa at Capri.
And you can see the shape of
that aula.
It's a kind of hemicycle with
large picture windows that allow
views that lie outside.
And it should remind you of the
second phase of the Villa of the
Mysteries in Pompeii,
where we also saw that
attractive bay window with the
panoramic views,
out beyond.
The panoramic views were much
more spectacular here than even
from the Villa of the Mysteries,
because as I think you can see
also from this site plan,
that this is located right at
the edge of a promontory.
It's in fact 1,095 feet above
sea level, and you get some
incredible views of the sea and
of other islands from this
location.
On this side,
the northern side of the
structure, is where the
apartments of Tiberius were
located;
a series of rooms for the
emperor himself,
and including also an imperial
loggia,
where he could walk out and get
some attractive panoramas
privately on his own.
You can also see that there is
a corridor that leads from the
private apartment to this very
long walkway,
that is located right at the
edge of the cliff on this side.
This is called technically an
ambulatio
--a-m-b-u-l-a-t-i-o,
an ambulatio--and it was
just for that.
It was for taking pleasant
walks, getting nice views of the
sea from there,
especially for the emperor and
special invited guests.
And right in the center was a
triclinium--
you see it right here--a
triclinium or dining room
where the emperor could dine and
could look out again over views
that were possible from this
particular locale.
This is a view unfortunately in
black and white,
but it's the only one that I
have that gives you a sense of
the remains today from above,
the extent of those remains.
And you can see again the
concrete construction I think
quite well from this,
as well as the fact that
although all the foundation
walls are there,
there's no decoration,
the ceilings are missing,
and so on and so forth.
You see the cistern here,
the location of the aula
up here, the area for the
entourage of Tiberius,
and the private apartment on
that side.
A church and a statue on a base
were added later,
and so of course you need to
think those away.
This is a view of some of the
remains as they look today,
just to give you a sense that
when you're actually up there
and wandering around.
The walls don't go up all that
far,
but you can also see that they
do preserve the entire plan of
the structure,
which is why we have such a
good idea of what it looked like
in antiquity and how all of
those pieces fit together.
You can see that the
construction is concrete and the
facing is stone,
irregular stonework,
the kind of opus
incertum work that we've
seen elsewhere in Campania.
Because remember this is an
island, but it's off the coast
of Naples, Pompeii and Oplontis;
it is in that same general area
of Italy.
And this is one view and one--I
have many more spectacular ones
than this one--
but this is one that gives you
a sense of the sort of thing you
can see.
This one I took right from,
I think from near the
aula;
just to give you an idea of
what you see from there.
Beautiful views of the sea.
In some areas you can see the
rocky outcroppings as you look
down, and then views of some
other islands in the area,
for example Ischia,
and so on.
The successor to Tiberius was a
man by the name of Caligula.
Caligula became emperor at the
death of Tiberius.
And we see a portrait of him
here, on the right-hand side of
the screen, just again to give
you a sense of the man.
He had a very short--he was
very young when he became
emperor of Rome--he had a very
short reign, only three years.
And he was somewhat unbalanced,
and it was not long after he
became emperor--oh,
by the way, he was very popular
when he was a boy;
he was a prince, very popular.
He used to run around the
military camps with his family,
in a little military costume,
and he wore these distinctive
military boots called the
caliga,
c-a-l-i-g-a;
which is how he got the
nickname Caligula,
from those boots.
He was extremely popular with
everyone, and everyone was quite
excited when he became emperor
of Rome.
But his power went to his head.
He became a despot,
and he spent most of his time
cavorting with his three
sisters.
I show you them here on a coin,
and they're all named:
Agrippina,
Julia, and--Drusilla was his
favorite,
so of course she's in the
center there--
Drusilla.
And he also did strange things
like conduct faux wars
essentially, faux wars with faux
enemies: for example,
his war against Britain,
so to speak.
And he also spent a good deal
of time trying to work it out so
that his horse,
Incitatus, could become a
senator.
So this gives you some idea of
the kind of man we're dealing
with here.
He was occupied with all of
that and really not that much
with architecture.
And again, he was only emperor
for a very short time,
so there was a limit to what
kinds of architectural
contributions he could make.
But he didn't make none.
I mean, he made some,
and in fact one of them is
particularly important,
and I want to emphasize those
to you here.
So again, Caligula was emperor
between 37 and 41 A.D.
He had little public building.
Again, he continued the
tradition of Tiberius,
and that is in having much more
interest in private villa
architecture than in public
architecture.
But again it's only fair--as we
judge him in terms of his
architectural contribution,
I think it's only fair to
remind ourselves that again he
was only emperor for three
years.
If he had been emperor longer,
perhaps his contribution would
have been greater.
He did finish several
buildings, begun by Tiberius--
and we're going to see this as
a pattern,
that is, emperors coming to the
fore and completing buildings by
their predecessors.
And he did build a couple of
new things, including two new
aqueducts and a circus located
near what is now Vatican City.
He thought the Domus Tiberiana
was a terrific idea and
consequently he added to that
palace;
that's the palace that Tiberius
began on the slopes of the
Palatine Hill.
But his main interest was
villas outside Rome.
He built a number of those.
I'm not talking about Capri
now, those were already built,
and he could go down and enjoy
those as emperor of Rome,
but he wanted to ring Rome with
a series of villas,
and he began that work.
And later on,
according to Pliny the Elder,
Rome was ringed with the
villas, not only of Caligula,
but also of Nero.
So these were going up apace
around the city of Rome itself.
The single most important
contribution though that
Caligula made,
and it is very significant,
is to alter--
it was during his reign,
during his brief reign,
that the recipe for Roman
concrete construction was
altered.
What they did was make the
decision to lighten it up,
and they did that by taking the
stone rubble that had been used
in the mixture of concrete for
some time,
taking that stone rubble and
dispensing with it,
getting rid of it,
because it was too heavy,
and mixed the liquid mortar
instead with a very porous,
yellow tufa,
and also with pumice,
which is a soft light stone
resembling cork.
So when you think of replacing
heavy rubble with something that
resembles cork,
you get the sense that that is
going to lead to lighter domes;
lighter domes are going to lead
to domes that are able to span
greater spaces.
So this is no small
accomplishment.
This is very, very significant.
It happens during the reign of
Caligula,
and we'll see already today
that the so-called Golden House
or Domus Aurea of Nero,
would not have been possible,
the span of that dome would not
have been possible without this
change in the recipe in concrete
that happened under Caligula.
The other development under
Caligula that I want to make
reference to really has more to
do with religious practice,
but it also has an important
impact on architecture,
and that is the impact of
mystery cults on Roman religion.
I think I've mentioned to you
already that the Romans
practiced a state religion,
and that state religion was
considered the religion that
everyone should adhere to.
But over time,
because of Rome's connections
to other parts of the empire,
especially the Eastern Empire,
a whole host of different kinds
of religions,
mystery religions,
exotic religions,
began to infiltrate Rome.
They came back through the
army, they came back through
commerce, to Rome.
And initially they were not
accepted.
You were not allowed to
practice these openly.
And so we saw an example with
the Villa of the Mysteries where
the woman of the house created a
special room,
room number five,
for the celebration of the cult
of Dionysus,
because that was considered a
secret religion at that
particular point.
But these mystery religions,
Caligula himself showed some
interest in them,
and it began to look as if
perhaps they would be able to
begin to come up from
underground.
They didn't during his reign,
but I think again his
contribution in that way was
also an important one.
They did continue to have to
meet in secret.
And one sect in particular I
want to make reference to today,
the so-called Neo-Pythagorean
sect,
because we'll see in the next
monument that I want to show
you,
that it was that sect that was
celebrated in a very interesting
underground basilica that I want
to turn to now.
It doesn't date to the time of
Caligula;
in fact, it's a little bit
later, in the reign of Claudius.
But I want to show it to you
here,
because again it was Caligula's
beginning to be more accepting
of these kinds of things that
led in part to their
proliferation,
initially underground and then
above ground as well.
This is the so-called
Underground Basilica,
because it is located
underground.
It dates to around A.D. 50.
And you can see from this site
plan its location.
You can see it marked
"basilica"
up there,
and you can see that it's near
a street we've already talked
about,
the Via Praenestina in Rome,
which you'll remember is one,
along with the Via Labicana,
that came and converged on the
Tomb of the Baker that we looked
at last time.
In fact, if you look at this
site plan, you see the
trapezoidal plan of the Tomb of
the Baker right here.
And when we discussed the Tomb
of the Baker,
I made the point to you that it
was located,
or it was sited,
in front of a great gate,
the so-called Porta Maggiore,
or the great gate that spanned
two aqueducts.
And I said to you,
I urged you to think away that
great gate because it was built
later.
It was built,
in fact, during the reign of
Claudius.
We're going to look at it
momentarily.
So you see the great gate here,
and you see the Tomb of the
Baker,
and that gives you a sense of
the location of the basilica,
the Underground Basilica of 50
A.D.
If you look at that basilica,
you see the plan is exactly
like the basilica in a civic
context--
the basilica at Pompeii,
for example--
with a central nave and two
side aisles,
divided by that nave,
that central space,
through architectural members,
in this case through piers
rather than columns;
and then at the end,
to give some emphasis to one
short side of the space,
an apse, that you also see
there.
This underground basilica was
used for religious worship.
So we see once again what I've
referred to as the
interchangeability of form:
the idea of creating a certain
building plan for a civic
center,
the law court or basilica,
and then using it in other
ways.
We already saw the basilican
plan being used in house design
at Herculaneum as a banqueting
hall,
and here we see it as a
religious, a place for religious
worship underground:
a basilican form being used for
religious worship underground.
The Underground Basilica is
miraculously preserved.
Why?
Because it's underground and it
didn't--it consequently was kept
in very good shape over time.
It's very difficult to get
permission to go down and see
it, but it is a marvel,
as you can see from this image
here.
How did they create this
Underground Basilica?
How did they make this building
underground?
Well they cut trenches in the
tufa rock, in the tufa rock;
remember we've talked about how
ubiquitous tufa rock was in
Rome, both on the hillsides,
like the Palatine,
and elsewhere.
So they cut trenches in the
tufa rock,
and then they poured concrete
into those trenches to create
the walls and also the barrel
vault that you see so well here.
And once that concrete had
dried, they cut it out in such a
way as to create the piers that
you also see very well in this
structure.
So we're looking at that
central space;
we're looking at the piers,
the arches above those piers,
and then that's supporting a
barrel vaulting ceiling,
as well as a semi-vault in the
apse of this structure.
Another view gives you a sense
of the relationship of the
central space to the aisles.
It's a fairly small structure
but nonetheless it is quite
light and airy,
as I think you can see here,
as we look from the central
nave toward one of the side
aisles.
You can see the piers and the
arches above those piers,
and you can also see the way in
which the walls are decorated.
They're made out of concrete
but they're stuccoed over and
divided into a series of panels
that are decorated with pretty
strong resemblance to Third
Style,
and that resemblance becomes
even clearer as we look up to
the vault above.
This is how we surmise that
this building was put up to the
Neo-Pythagorean cult,
because of the figures that we
see floating in the central
panels here.
Those who have a good
understanding of the
Neo-Pythagorean cult have
suggested that these track
extremely well the beliefs of
this particular cult.
But interesting for us is again
the close resemblance of this to
Third Style Roman wall painting.
It's done in stucco.
The stucco is painted,
but you can see it's divided
into a series of panels with
floating mythological figures,
or floating religious figures
in this case,
inside the panels.
And look then very carefully at
some of the floral decorations,
which you will see also
resemble very closely the flimsy
candelabra and so on that are
characteristic of Third Style
Roman painting.
This shouldn't surprise you.
The date of 50 A.D.
is still well within the Third
Style.
We've talked about the very
long life of the Third Style,
that it was used already in the
late first century B.C.,
but that it didn't really go
out until about 62 A.D.
So 50 was still in that period
of the Third Style;
it doesn't surprise us to see
decoration like this,
in this very interesting
Underground Basilica.
Caligula was murdered in 41,
and his wife and daughter--he
had one daughter--were also
murdered at the same time.
He had no family member to
succeed him, and his uncle
Claudius was chosen as the next
emperor of Rome.
Many of you may know the
interesting story,
quite captivating story,
of how Claudius was chosen as
emperor.
He was someone who was not
highly respected by his
family--and I'll say more about
that in a moment;
no one ever thought he was
going to amount to anything.
And when, after Caligula's
death, Claudius was such,
kind of timid,
that he hid behind a curtain.
But as the Praetorian Guard
wandered through the palace,
trying to figure out who in the
world they were going to appoint
as Caligula's successor,
they saw a pair of feet
underneath a curtain.
They pulled open that curtain
and they saw Claudius,
and they thought,
"Well he's going to be no
trouble at all.
No one thinks much of him.
We're going to be able to get
everything we want if we appoint
Claudius as emperor."
And so they did,
they bowed down,
and they said,
"You are now--",
or they put him up on their
shoulders,
"You are now emperor of
Rome."
Well Claudius surprised them
because he was a very smart
individual indeed,
as we shall see.
This is a cameo,
a famous cameo that represents
Claudius,
just for you to get some sense
of what he looked like,
over here on the left,
with his wife,
and then possibly--these two
figures over here are
controversial--
possibly with Tiberius or some
other member of the imperial
family.
This is blown up into colossal
size.
It's a fairly small but very
beautiful cameo,
and these cameos were used as
presentation pieces in ancient
Roman times.
Claudius was emperor of Rome
between A.D.
41 and 54.
I mentioned that his family did
not have much respect for him.
They thought he was weak and
sickly, and they thought he was
dim-witted.
And the only reason they
thought he was dim-witted,
because the poor fellow
stammered, and they thought that
that reflected an undisciplined
mind.
Not at all, he was very,
very intelligent indeed,
and he surprised them.
He surprised not only the
Praetorian Guard but also his
family, when he became emperor.
He turned out to be a unique
individual with a predilection,
as we shall see,
for an entirely new kind of,
and very distinctive form of
architecture,
and one that I believe--and
I'll try to make the case to you
today--
reflected his very distinctive
intellect.
We need to know therefore
something about him and how he
came--how he had trained himself
intellectually before he became
emperor of Rome.
He was fifty-years-old when he
became emperor.
He had been,
in the years prior to that,
a scholar, an historian,
an antiquarian,
a linguist.
He wrote a history of Rome by
himself--it was not
ghostwritten--and he wrote
several volumes,
also on his own,
on the Etruscans;
he was particularly interested
in the Etruscans.
We know he added a few letters
to the Latin alphabet to give it
more range,
and he was the last Roman,
as far as we know,
to be able to read and also
write Etruscan.
This gives you a very good
sense of the man.
With regard to architecture,
he rejected categorically the
interests of Tiberius and
Caligula in villa architecture,
and he returned to the
construction of public
architecture--
he looked to Augustus as a
model for this--
and especially to public works.
Let me show you one example.
You see on the screen a site
plan of the port of Rome.
I've already mentioned the fact
that the port of Rome was
located at Ostia,
Ostia the city at the mouth of
the Tiber River.
We saw the plan of Ostia,
a colony already founded in the
mid-fourth century B.C.,
in around 350,
and it grew over time and it
had its efflorescence,
as we'll see in a later
lecture, in the second century
A.D.
Here the plan of Ostia over
here.
The Tiber River,
and then at the mouth of the
Tiber River,
at a place that we call Portus,
a location that we call Portus
or Porto--
it's on the Monument List for
you--the actual harbor itself.
What we're looking at above is
a coin of the emperor Nero.
You see Nero on the obverse and
on the reverse a representation
of what we think is the port
built by Claudius.
We have a description of the
port of Claudius by Suetonius in
his Lives.
Suetonius tells us that the
port had curving breakwaters,
curving breakwaters.
And if we look at this coin of
Nero that was struck by the
emperor between 64 and 68 A.D.,
we see on the back what is
clearly a port,
with curving breakwaters.
So we believe that this must be
a depiction of the port built by
Claudius sometime during his
reign, that is,
between 41 and 54.
What does that coin tell us
about what that port must have
looked like?
We can see that there is a
large statue in the upper
center.
There is a river god reclining
below, probably the Tiber
himself, to locate this port,
and also a series of boats in
the center.
But most important again are
the curving breakwaters,
which you can see are made up
of a series of columns;
they look like colonnades,
one on either side,
curving colonnades.
This plan down here shows us
the likely plan of the Claudian
harbor,
roughly circular,
again with breakwaters on
either side,
with columns on either side.
This area was added to by the
emperor Trajan,
in the early second century
A.D.
He added a five-sided port as
well, and you can see that here,
in this plan as well.
But think that away for now.
All that would've been there
was Claudius' port with the
curving breakwaters.
This is a painting of both of
those ports, that's on the wall
in the Vatican.
I've walked by it many times
and only recently really noticed
it and took a picture of it,
and I think it'll be helpful to
you today because it gives you a
sense of what this port looked
like in antiquity.
We see the later port of Trajan
over here.
But again think that away for
now and concentrate on the
curving breakwaters of Claudius'
port.
You see here this colossal
statue, possibly of Neptune,
over here, a lighthouse,
over here, and the boats in the
center of this.
But most important for us again
are those curving breakwaters
and the fact that they were made
up of columns.
The columns are all that
survive today,
and what a set of columns they
are.
I show a detail of some of them
to you here.
And you should be struck by
these columns,
because these are columns
unlike any other columns that we
have seen in the course of this
semester.
If you look at these columns
very carefully,
you will see that the capitals
on the top,
which are very severe--they're
not exactly the Doric order but
they resemble the Doric order--
very severe,
and they are finished;
you can identify them as
capitals.
And the bases,
I'll show you a view of the
bases in a moment,
the bases, as we'll also see,
are also finished with very
nice moldings down below.
But in between the bases and
the capitals,
we see something again that
we've never seen before,
and that is a series of drums,
of column drums,
piled one on top of another.
But those drums are not
finished, or they're left in a
rough state -- one or the other.
They have either been
deliberately left in a rough or
rusticated state,
or they were unfinished.
Why might they have been
unfinished?
They might have been unfinished
because the project was late,
they were rushing it,
they wanted to get it done,
they needed to use the harbor,
and so they said,
"Look, to save time just
put those columns up the way
they are and don't bother
finishing the drums of the
column."
Or one could argue that it
might have had to do with
expense,
that it was getting too
expensive, and that they decided
not to finish the drums for that
reason.
Or it might have been
deliberate, or it might have
been deliberate:
the idea to leave those drums
rough, to make them look
rusticated.
I'm going to make a case today
that it's the last,
that this was a deliberate move
on Claudius and his architects.
And one of the main reasons I
can make that--
if this is all we had,
if we had only this port of
Claudius,
only these columns in this
style, it would be very
difficult to make the case.
But as we're going to see,
when we move from this to that
great gate,
or the Porta Maggiore,
which was put up under
Claudius,
and then not today but next
time, to a building that was put
up in Claudius' honor after his
death,
we will see that all three of
those have these rusticated
columns or piers in common,
which suggests to us--it
suggests to me for sure--
that these are--that leaving
them in this rusticated state
was deliberate on the part of
the patron and his architects.
And I'm also going to suggest
that it had to do with Claudius'
peculiar personality,
and especially his interest in
antiquarianism,
in the past,
in the history of Rome,
and the history of the
Etruscans, and so on.
Here's another detail of one of
the columns over here,
where you can see the rough
drum, and then down below the
base on which that sits,
a molded base,
very carefully molded.
The architects,
the designers,
the artisans could finish these
columns perfectly well if they
chose to.
They did it on the base,
they did it in the capitals,
but not in between.
Here's another one where you
can see a series of columns
engaged into a wall,
and again you can see the rough
or rusticated drums.
Then down below the molded and
finished bases.
So this difference between what
we call finished masonry or
dressed--
d-r-e-s-s-e-d--dressed masonry,
or rusticated masonry:
masonry that is deliberately
left rough.
Again, in order to underscore
this point,
I want to turn now to the great
gate or the Porta Maggiore in
Rome,
also built by Claudius between
41 and 54 A.D.
You already know its location,
near the Tomb of Eurysaces,
near the Underground Basilica
that we also discussed today.
And I had mentioned to you
already that the purpose of this
gate was to serve as a crossing
point for two aqueducts:
aqueducts that had been begun
earlier,
were worked on by Caligula,
and then completed by Claudius.
And there were two of them that
crossed at this very point,
and they needed something to
mask that crossing,
and so they built this great
gate, the Porta Maggiore.
If you look at this general
view of the Porta Maggiore,
you will see much of what I
have already described.
It has two open archways.
The uppermost part,
which is the attic,
which has an inscription--it's
a three-tiered attic,
as you can see,
and if you look carefully you
will see it has an extensive
inscription,
making reference to Claudius
and to the aqueducts and so on.
Down below we see a series of
smaller arcuations,
surrounded by columns on either
side, supporting pediments
above.
If you look closely you can see
that the pediments are finished,
the pediments are finished,
the lintels are finished,
the capitals are finished,
but the blocks of the column
and the blocks of the rest of
the structure are left in a
rusticated state.
They are not finished,
and we see that very stark
difference between the
rusticated masonry and the
finished masonry:
the smooth masonry,
the dressed masonry and the
rough masonry in this structure.
This gate, by the way,
is made out of
travertine--travertine cut stone
construction.
Here's another view that I
think shows you better the way
in which this gate masks the
crossing of those two aqueducts.
You can see two channels there,
and one would have had pipes
running through it one way and
the other would have had pipes
running through it the other
way,
and that's how they crossed in
antiquity.
And I'll show you a model that
may make that even clearer in a
moment.
You can also see the location
of the Tomb of the baker
Eurysaces right next to the
so-called Porta Maggiore.
Here's the model that I showed
you when we looked at the Tomb
of Eurysaces,
the way in which the
Praenestina and the Labicana
come into Rome and converge at
the faade of that tomb.
Here you see the great gate or
Porta Maggiore behind it.
And this is the best
illustration I can give of the
way in which those two,
the pipes of the two aqueducts,
cross behind the attic of the
gate,
which is one of the reasons it
had to be as tall as it did,
and one of the reasons it had
to have tiers was in order--
because it was separated behind.
You can see that very well
here, as well as the rusticated,
the contrast between the
rusticated masonry and the
finished masonry of this great
gate.
This combination of the two is
a very mannered thing to do,
and it's interesting that later
Renaissance architects in
Italy--
and for those of you who are
aficionados of the Renaissance,
you may know the work of an
architect by the name of Giulio
Romano who created the famous
Palazzo del Te in Mantua.
And I show you a detail of the
Palazzo del Te,
just to make the point,
the more general point--
you don't have to worry about
Giulio--
but just to make the general
point that these Renaissance
architects,
like Giulio Romano,
looked back to buildings like
the Porta Maggiore in Rome when
they also conceived of buildings
in which they contrasted
rusticated masonry with smooth
masonry,
as you can also see so well.
And here are two last details
of the Porta Maggiore,
and I think these show you,
almost more than anything else
I have thus far,
this incredible contrast
between the finished and the
unfinished masonry,
between the smooth and the
rough.
And here you see,
you can see a detail of the
pediment, of the smoothness of
that;
of the lintel down below;
of the capital,
which is completely finished;
and then even of the uppermost
part of the column.
And this is a particularly
interesting detail,
I think, because it gives me
the sense,
as I look at it,
that what the patron and
architects are trying to do is
give us a sense that the column
actually lives inside the
rusticated drums.
I get the sense as I look at
this that this finished column
is just--is very anxious to bust
out of the rusticated masonry in
which it is confined;
it's very anxious to emerge
from that rusticated masonry.
And I can't help but think of
the Renaissance again,
and especially of Michelangelo.
For any of who've seen his
slaves in the Accademia in
Florence,
the slaves that seem to--he
took these big blocks of Carrara
marble,
and he represents the slaves as
if they are still immersed in
that marble,
but trying to break free from
as if these images of human
beings were somehow located
inside that marble and just
waiting for the genius
Michelangelo to free them from
that marble.
It's the same sense that I get
here when I look at this,
and it makes me think again
that a very intelligent,
a very refined mind is behind
sorting out this kind of thing,
and conceiving of something of
this nature.
And given the education and the
bent of Claudius,
he is just the kind of man who
might have done that.
And I think we need to see the
architecture of Claudius,
this rusticated architecture of
Claudius,
which is contrasted to the
smooth and finished
architecture,
at the same time,
as something that really is
reflective of the peculiar
personality of this man.
I think it's also important to
say though that this kind of
architecture,
at this time,
is very old-fashioned.
The whole idea of using cut
stone travertine construction,
after what we've seen is going
on in concrete construction,
is a very old-fashioned thing
to do,
and again shows us a man who is
looking to the past,
who's looking to the history of
Rome,
to the history of the
Etruscans, perhaps rather than
to the present.
But, on the positive side,
one could also say that what he
is doing here,
he is using stone construction,
but he is using it in a very
different way,
and indeed an almost
anti-classical way,
to the way in which Augustus
used it.
Think of Augustus' Ara Pacis.
Think of Augustus' Temple of
Mars Ultor in the Forum of
Augustus in Rome.
Both of those marble buildings,
in that case Luna or Carrara
marble, based on ancient Greek
prototypes.
This is also stone
architecture,
and in that sense again
old-fashioned,
but it's travertine,
not marble.
But it is anti-classical in its
use of this rusticated,
as well as smooth masonry.
So I do want you to ponder this
architecture of Claudius and
think for yourselves about
whether you think again it is
due,
the form that it takes is due
to the very interesting and
unusual personality of this one
man.
From Claudius,
I want to turn to the notorious
Nero, and his amazing
architectural legacy.
And you see a portrait of Nero
here, on the right-hand side of
the screen, and a coin with his
mother on the left.
The mother of Nero was
Agrippina the Younger.
Agrippina the Younger was the
last wife of Claudius,
and it was rumored that
Agrippina the Younger murdered
Claudius with a bowl of poisoned
mushrooms.
We don't know if that's true or
not, it may be just rumor
mongering.
But it's perfectly conceivable
because she certainly had a
motive,
and that is she thought she
would have more power if her
teenage son--
because he was only about
17-years-old at the time--
was on the throne of Rome,
instead of her older husband.
And this coin that you see on
the left-hand side of the
screen, of the young Nero and
Agrippina I think says it all;
I mean, mother and son almost
nose to nose.
This gives real meaning to
being 'in your face';
as you can see here,
Agrippina is certainly in the
face of Nero on this coin.
And she was with regard to his
life, dominating him in the very
early years of his reign.
Nero was born in A.D. 37.
He was emperor between 54 and
68.
At his death,
his murder--he was forced to
commit suicide actually in 68--
he suffered a damnatio
memoriae,
which was a condemnation by the
Senate of him,
a damnation of his memory;
and an attempt to destroy his
portraits,
and also his architectural
monuments,
followed that damnatio
memoriae. Nero was the last
of the Julio-Claudian emperors.
He was the adoptive son of
Claudius, and as I've already
mentioned the real son of
Claudius' last wife,
Agrippina the Elder .
I mentioned already that
Agrippina--or I gave you the
sense--that Agrippina was a
quite aggressive woman who
aggravated Claudius and Nero
both.
We talked about the poisoned
mushroom stories,
and the fact that when her son
became emperor,
she received,
at least for a while,
enhanced power in Rome.
But Nero eventually paid his
mother back by having her
murdered in A.D.
59.
He also got rid of his wife
Octavia, a beautiful young girl
whom he had murdered in 62.
So by the age of 25,
Nero had gotten rid of the
women,
the two women,
who had dominated his youth,
and his much-touted madness--he
was not unlike Caligula in some
of the wild things that he did--
his much-touted madness began
to appear.
That said, despite his madness,
he was absolutely adored by the
populace.
It was a great show to watch
Nero, and people liked seeing
what he would do next.
He was adored by the populace.
He was however hated by the
aristocracy and in 68,
he was hunted down by his
enemies and he was forced to
commit suicide.
I would call Nero a patron of
architecture extraordinaire.
His contribution to the
development of Roman
architecture is indeed
extraordinary.
He had a passion for the arts,
which undoubtedly led to his
devotion to building.
He wrote and he sang poems.
Nero was a musician.
He collected Greek works of art.
He traveled to Greece to
participate in the Olympics.
Whenever he did that,
they were always fixed in his
favor.
When he traveled around Greece
and Asia Minor,
he stole--if he saw a work of
art he liked,
he stole it,
and he brought it back to Rome
to display.
He interwove his life with his
art, in the same manner as
Claudius did.
He took advantage of that very
famous fire in Rome,
which took place in 64 A.D.,
to--legend has it that he
fiddled while Rome burned.
He wasn't fiddling actually but
he was participating in some
sort of musical performance;
we know that.
And after the fire raged
through the city and caused
incredible havoc and great
destruction,
what Nero did was instead of
rebuilding the land for the
people of Rome,
he just expropriated 300 to 350
acres of prime real estate in
downtown Rome,
and he used it to build his own
villa,
his own palace,
in the center of Rome,
the famous Domus Aurea or
Golden House,
because it had a gilded
faade.
Nero's architecture was
intimately bound up with the
vicissitudes of his life and his
distinctive, if not warped,
personality,
as we shall see.
Nero built two palaces in Rome,
and I'd like to begin with the
one--I'd like to deal with those
in consecutive order.
The first of these,
as you can see from the
Monument List,
is the so-called Domus
Transitoria--
the less well-known one and
less well-preserved one--
the Domus Transitoria in Rome
that was built sometime before
the fire,
before A.D.
64, because it was very
significantly destroyed in that
fire of A.D.
64.
I'm showing you a Google Earth
image of the part of Rome in
which this building found
itself.
We are looking down--we've seen
this one before--
we are looking down at the
Roman Forum,
the Colosseum in the uppermost
part there,
the Palatine Hill over here.
And if we follow the Roman
Forum toward the Colosseum and
toward the later Arch of
Constantine,
we will see that there is a
spur hill over,
and that spur hill is located
between the Palatine Hill and
one of Rome's other hills,
the Esquiline--E-s-q
-u-i-l-i-n-e--the Esquiline
Hill.
Nero's dream was to link the
buildings that were going up on
the Palatine.
We've already talked about the
Imperial Palace,
begun by Tiberius,
continued by Caligula.
Claudius had no interest in
that.
But then Nero returns to it,
and he's continuing to build
this palace on the Palatine.
But his dream is to link that
with property that he also owns
on the Esquiline Hill,
and to make one truly grandiose
palace that links those two
hills,
across a spur hill called the
Velia,
V-e-l-i-a, which is in this
uppermost part of the Roman
Forum,
closest to the Colosseum.
That was his dream,
and he began to try to realize
it prior to 64 A.D.
The building is called the
Domus Transitoria because it
served as a point of transit
between those two hills,
between the Palatine and the
Esquiline Hills.
Again, because it was so
seriously destroyed in fire,
and also because it was
deliberately destroyed by later
emperors who were following the
damnation,
the damnatio memoriae,
the damnation of Nero's memory,
and felt that it was their
right, in a sense,
to destroy his buildings.
So those two things together,
deliberate destruction plus the
fire, essentially destroyed most
of the Domus Transitoria.
But a couple of sections are
preserved underground,
and they're very important for
us to look at because they give
us insight into the later Golden
House or Domus Aurea.
I want to show you the two
sections that are still
preserved in restored views that
you will find in your textbook,
in Ward-Perkins.
One of these is located beneath
the--
while this is still on the
screen, if you look at the
Palatine Palace here,
just a little bit up beyond
where my finger is,
there is the dining hall of the
later first century A.D.
palace that we'll look at soon,
next week.
You see it there.
And one of the buildings,
a fountain of Nero's Domus
Transitoria, is located under
that.
And then over here,
this temple that you see right
close to the Colosseum,
is a later Hadrianic Temple of
Venus and Roma.
The domed room that I'm going
to show you, is under that.
So both of these are
underground, beneath later
structures.
This is a restored view from
Ward-Perkins of the fountain,
the fountain court of Nero's
Domus Transitoria,
and we see a number of
important features.
We see an open court with a
pool, with columns around it.
On the northern wall over here,
we see the fountain itself.
We see that what the architects
have done is create,
using a niche,
a place in that niche,
a series of other niches,
that served as the location of
the actual water from which the
fountain emerged,
and the water would cascade
over this wall down here,
and then end up in a long basin
in front of it.
The wall is what's most
interesting.
If you look at it,
you will see that it is
essentially scalloped,
with columns in the front and
then additional columns in the
receding bays,
creating a kind of in-and-out
effect,
very similar to theater
architecture,
and I show you a restored view
of a typical theater,
of earlier date,
just to give you a sense of
what this is based on.
You can also see that opening
up off this central court,
screened by columns,
are barrel-vaulted rooms on
either side.
These were used as special
dining areas;
so special dining areas with
beautiful views out onto this
fountain court on either side.
And then this restored view
also gives you a sense that the
pavements were variegated,
were done in different designs.
And we know that these
pavements were made out of
marble and that the walls were
revetted with marble.
This isn't the faux marble of
the First Style,
this is real marble,
and it's our first example in
Rome of a room that was revetted
with marble,
brought from all parts of the
world: marble brought from
Africa,
marble brought from Egypt,
marble brought from Asia Minor
and also from Greece,
in various colors,
to decorate the fountain court
of Nero's Domus Transitoria.
The other room,
and perhaps the more important
of the two,
is the domed room--definitely
more important of the two--
the domed room in the Domus
Transitoria of Nero.
And you see a restored view of
it here.
What are we dealing with?
We are dealing with a structure
that is clearly based on the
thermal bath at Baia and the
frigidaria of Pompeii.
It is a concrete structure.
It looks as if it's round.
In fact, you can see a circle
inscribed in the pavement,
down here below.
The structure is made out of
concrete.
It has a dome and an
oculus.
But even though it is inscribed
in a circle,
if you look carefully at the
walls,
you will see that although they
are curved--
they follow the curvature of
the circle--
there are eight sides to this
wall.
So the architect is starting to
explore the idea of an octagon.
This is not an octagon--it's a
circle inscribed in an octagon,
in a sense--but it is an
exploration into an eight-sided
form,
that we're going to see is
very, very important for a later
development in the Golden House
of Nero.
Also what we see here that's
very interesting,
that's a further development of
the frigidarium and
thermal bath idea,
is instead of this circular
structure and an octagon ending
with these radiating apses,
the four radiating apses that
we saw at Baia,
for example,
we see that they extend into
corridors on either side,
which expands the space in a
way that we have not seen
before.
You see, they don't end on
either side with these apses
with walls,
they expand into these long
corridors,
as you can see,
creating a kind of cross shape,
and certainly adding to the
interesting spatial
relationships and spatial
possibilities,
and the use again of vista and
panorama,
as we've seen.
We see here also,
on either side here,
a series of columns with metal
grills on top:
so wonderful views through
those columns to what lies
beyond.
And then on this side,
a small pool that had white
marble and then colored marbles
around that.
So you have to imagine again
the overall appearance of this
in antiquity,
when light would have streamed
through the dome of the central
space,
onto the walls that probably
had mosaic on them,
through the grills and the
columns,
onto the water of the white
pool here,
which was also surrounded with
variegated marbles --
these same marbles brought from
all over the world.
The view must have been quite
spectacular.
This is certainly again a form
of ostentatious palatial
architecture that Augustus
eschewed,
but was becoming of increasing
interest to the likes of
Tiberius,
Caligula, and ultimately Nero.
And again, just to make the
same point again,
we can trace this back to the
experiments of the
frigidaria at Pompeii:
that's the Stabian Baths too,
the thermal bath,
the Temple of Mercury at Baia.
But look at the difference that
it makes when you extend those
apses into corridors,
creating a much freer spatial
situation and adding to the
vista and panorama idea that has
been so popular,
as we've long seen,
with the Romans.
In the time that remains,
I want to turn to Nero's most
important architectural
commission,
and I can't over-emphasize the
significance of this structure
that I'm going to show you now,
the so-called Domus Aurea or
the Golden House of Nero,
again because of its gilded
faade.
We've already talked about the
fire that raged through Rome in
64,
and that when that fire,
when the smoke from that fire
died down,
that Nero expropriated 300 to
350 acres in prime downtown
Rome,
for his own use,
for a private palace,
the so-called Golden House.
We see a site plan here,
also from Ward-Perkins,
where you can get a sense,
not only of the extent of
this--
look how it covers ground from
the Circus Maximus,
all the way across,
to the Esquiline Hill,
as you can see so well here.
So the Palatine Hill,
the Esquiline Hill,
and also even the Caelian Hill
over here.
He dug an artificial -- or he
had his architects dig an
artificial lake in the center of
this, as you can see here.
And the Golden House was very
extensive.
There's only one part of it
that remains today,
under the--or as part of the
Esquiline Hill in Rome,
and we therefore call it the
Esquiline Wing of the Domus
Aurea of Nero.
This palace had an incredible
set of gimmicks,
gimmicks that were so
noteworthy that the names of the
architects have come down to us,
the architect and engineer who
are responsible for this.
And I think it is largely they
came down to us largely because
of these incredible gimmicks
that they created for this
structure.
Their names were Severus and
Celer;
Severus and Celer.
And I believe I have put their
names on the Monument List for
you.
Yes I have, underneath the plan
of the Esquiline Wing.
So Severus and Celer;
their names suggest to us that
they were Roman architects,
in fact.
And these gimmicks included a
125-foot statue of Nero himself,
a colossal stature--or the
Colossus,
as it is designated here--a
colossal statue of Nero
assimilated to the sun god Sol,
S-o-l, the sun god Sol,
and it was done in bronze and
it was done by a famous artist,
whose name we also know,
Zenodorus--
I've also put his name on the
Monument List for you--
Zenodorus, who was a very
famous bronze caster.
So Zenodorus' Colossus,
the gilded faade.
And what were some of the
gimmicks that Severus and Celer
added to this palace?
When you ate in the dining
hall, if you were invited as a
special guest to eat with Nero,
while you were eating the
coffered ceilings of one of the
dining rooms would drop on you
all kinds of wonderful
fragrances and flower petals,
while you ate.
There was also a bath that gave
you a choice of sea water and
salt water and water from the
sulfur springs of Tivoli;
you had your choice,
if you were bathing at Nero's
Domus Aurea.
And most spectacularly of all,
and I think what Severus and
Celer had particular fame for,
was they created a banqueting
room that had a revolving
ceiling,
supposedly, a ceiling that
revolved with the heavenly
bodies.
So an incredible array of
gimmicks,
as I said before,
in this extraordinary palace,
but all of them clearly
possible vis--vis
architecture at this time.
I'm showing you here a plan of
the Esquiline Wing.
This is the one part of the
palace that survives today.
We'll talk about what happened
to this palace in a later
lecture, but you can see it
here.
Dozens and dozens of rooms
around a five-sided court,
as you can see at this
location.
And then here,
what is the so-called octagonal
room of Nero's Domus Aurea,
which is a remarkable room.
And I think it's fair to say
the single most important room
that I will have shown you thus
far this semester is the
octagonal room of Nero's Domus
Aurea.
And you see it here.
You can see the plan of the
octagon, and then the radiating
spaces out from it.
I'll return to that plan in
just a moment.
Just to mention though,
by using Google Earth again,
I can show you the particular
location of the Esquiline Wing
on the Esquiline Hill today.
What happened to it
eventually--and again I'm not
going to go into the details now
but I will in the future--
after Nero's damnatio
memoriae,
some of this was destroyed and
much of it was incorporated into
later buildings.
Eventually a bath of the
emperor Trajan ended up on this
site,
and the emperor covered over
what remained of Nero's Domus
Aurea,
what hadn't been razed to the
ground,
and incorporated some of it
into his later bath.
And, in fact,
this hemicycle of Trajan's
Baths is actually the
entranceway today of the Domus
Aurea.
You can see it right here,
and you can see that the other
remains of both Trajan's Baths
and of the Domus Aurea have been
incorporated into a modern
garden,
a very attractive garden where
you can wander and see some of
the remains of both.
And actually what you see
here--it just shows how amazing
Google Earth is--
this circle that you see here
is actually--
it has a grate on top
today--but it is actually the
oculus of Nero's
octagonal room,
which is down below,
which is located underground.
So if you visit the Domus
Aurea, which is,
as you can see,
right near the Colosseum,
you go into the entranceway
through the hemicycle of
Trajan's later baths,
and you find yourself in a
series of corridors.
We've talked about these
corridors before,
because we talked about the
paintings that Fabullus did,
for Nero's Domus Aurea;
first the Third Style paintings
and then the Fourth Style
paintings.
And you'll remember that the
Domus Aurea was described as
Fabullus' prison,
because there were so many
rooms and corridors that it
would take a whole lifetime to
paint them.
And you see some of those here:
barrel vaulted corridors,
stuccoed over,
and then painted in the Third
and Fourth styles.
Another gimmick that you see
throughout the Domus Aurea are a
series of bridges that are built
to carry water from one part of
the palace to another.
Another view here showing one
of the corridors,
and what you see here is
something that we have not
discussed yet,
but is the wave of the future,
and that is concrete faced with
brick.
After the fire there was
realization--
the fire of 64--there was
realization that stone burned
too easily,
it was not an effective facing
any longer,
and that they needed to come up
with something else.
Brick worked better with fire.
So the decision was taken to
move--and this is not the tile
brick in Pompeii,
this is real brick--and the
decision was taken to begin to
use brick-faced construction for
these buildings.
At this time it was stuccoed
over, as you can see here:
stucco, and then painted on
top.
So you wouldn't have actually
seen the brick in antiquity,
but we'll see it was not long
until the Romans recognized that
brick was a very attractive
material in its own right,
and began to leave it exposed.
But we're not there yet.
The paintings,
the Fourth Style paintings of
Fabullus.
You'll remember this one that
we've already looked at,
with the reintroduction of
architectural fragments and the
architectural cages in the Domus
Aurea.
This is the single--as I've
already said--
the single most remarkable and
important room that I've shown
you thus far this semester,
the octagonal room in Nero's
Domus Aurea.
You see this cross-section
plan, an axonometric view from
Ward-Perkins here.
And you can get a very good
sense of this.
This is truly an octagonal room.
The experiment in the domed
room, where they had inscribed a
circle into an octagon,
gave them the idea that they
were going to try to make an
actual octagonal room out of
concrete,
and they succeed here.
You can see the eight sides of
this room.
You can see it has a series of
radiating alcoves,
but much bigger alcoves than we
saw in the frigidaria at
Pompeii,
or in the thermal bath at Baia,
and differently shaped ones--
not all the same,
but a couple are cross-shaped
and others are rectangular--
different shapes.
And then the axonometric view
shows you that within those
alcoves there are additional
niches in some of the walls that
give more of a sculptural
quality to this than has been
the case before.
And this again was no small
feat on the part of these
architects.
Why is the Domus Aurea so
important--excuse me--the
octagonal room of the Domus
Aurea so important?
The octagonal room of the Domus
Aurea--
and I've given you a number of
bullet points here--
represents a break from the
tyranny of the rectangle,
the tyranny of the rectangle
that we know from Greek and
Etruscan architecture.
It enables vistas to be created
in every direction,
and you know the importance to
Romans of vistas and panoramas.
It creates one continuous
envelope around an interior
space.
It fully realizes--this
development has been long in
coming but we're finally there--
it fully realizes the technical
and expressive potentiality of
Roman concrete construction.
It represents a switch of
emphasis from solids to voids --
from walls and roofs that we
saw in such buildings as the
Temple of Portunus,
to the insubstantial space that
they enclose and shape.
It is the interior space,
not the walls that matter now.
And in this new interior
architecture,
light plays a key role:
natural light that creates
drama, as well as illuminates.
The importance of the octagonal
room of Nero's Domus Aurea
cannot be overstated!!!
The octagonal room heralds the
Roman architectural revolution
that we saw already beginning at
places like Palestrina,
but it is finally here,
in its full-blown form;
whereas I said the potentiality
of the expressiveness of Roman
concrete is fully realized.
This is the room itself,
as it looks today.
We can see the octagon,
we can see the dome.
We can see the way in which the
octagon becomes the dome,
the eight sides and the way it
is shaped to become the dome
above.
We can see some of the niches
here.
We can see the way in which the
spaces expand from the central
space, and we can see niches
within those,
to give a greater sculptural
quality to it.
And you can get a little bit of
the sense of the light here.
This would have been
elaborately decorated in
antiquity.
I show you a restored view.
All of those same marbles,
from Egypt, from Africa,
from Asia Minor,
from Greece,
all brought together here;
lots of different colors.
This is what those Pompeians
wished their walls actually
looked like.
But you see real marble
revetted walls,
marble pavements,
and then up above --
in all kinds of colors -- and
then up above the ceiling
stuccoed over and also painted.
One can only imagine Nero
entering into this octagonal
room, and how he must have felt.
And, in fact,
we have a quote from Nero,
in which he says that when the
Domus Aurea in Rome was
finished--
or he's reported to have said,
when the Domus Aurea in Rome
was finished--
he's reported to have said,
and I quote:
"At last,
at last, I am going to be able
to be housed like a human
being."
That was the way Nero thought
about this.
He achieved his goal,
undoubtedly,
at least for a short period of
time before he died in 68.
And I believe--and I'm sure you
agree with me--
I believe that it is for the
Domus Aurea,
especially for the octagonal
room of the Domus Aurea,
that Nero would have liked to
be remembered,
and indeed he achieved his goal.
Thank you.